today we're talking about a new cloud
region
information sharing and healthcare
and increasing open source security
my name is anthony and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
we are very excited to announce a new
cloud region in mexico
when it launches this new cloud region
will be our third in latin america
joining santiago chile and sao paulo
brazil among the 34 regions and 103
zones currently in operation all around
the world each delivering high
performance low latency cloud services
to customers of all sizes and industries
this new region will help support the
digital transformations of enterprises
cloud native companies and even public
sector organizations
google cloud recently announced that it
is partnering with health information
sharing and analysis center as an
ambassador partner
last august google announced its
commitment to invest at least 10 billion
dollars over the next five years to
advance cyber security
we're excited to be working with
organizations like health isac
and those on the forefront of building
communities and protecting societies
on the journey to being resilient one
thing is for certain working together
can make all the difference
check out the blog for more details on
this exciting partnership building on
the momentum of the csrb's first report
on log4j library vulnerabilities
discovered in late 2021 we are going to
share google's approach to address the
report's recommendations
we see this as an important part of our
effort to support others in the industry
as we all work together to increase open
source security
this includes driving adoption of best
practices
building a better software ecosystem and
making long-term investments in digital
security
together these efforts demonstrate the
steps we're taking to protect others and
reflect our broader commitment to
improve security for everyone
for more details on google's approach
check out the blog post if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or even tweet us we'll see you in the
cloud
you